si a mí me gustaría destacar dos cosas
sobre esta gira en primer lugar la
relevancia que tiene y en segundo lugar
su trascendencia es relevante porque
bueno el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador ha salido muy pocas veces de
méxico no tiene una política una buena
imagen en el caso de la política
exterior que dice que la mejor política
exterior es la política interior y
entonces no se ha involucrado mucho en
la escena internacional
ha salido tres veces esta es la cuarta
vez que salen las otras tres veces por
en eeuu y fueron por cuestiones de alta
relevancia como la adopción del tratado
de libre comercio la cumbre de líderes
de américa del norte y también la
presidencia de méxico del consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas entonces
esta cuarta
gira que hacen en todos los años día de
mandato y lleva tres años en la
presidencia es trascendental también
porque bueno
recién en eeuu se lanzaron las hípicas
la oficina encargada del control de
fronteras de eeuu lanza y hago
desclasifican las estadísticas de los
cruces migratorios que están
aconteciendo en la frontera méxico-eeuu
y vemos que en el primer trimestre de
2022 se han disparado estos estos cruces
entonces pareciera que estos programas
de emblema que ha venido promoviendo
méxico no están dando los resultados
esperados y bueno esa es la intención de
ir a centroamérica
por tanto no hay ningún acuerdo previo
con eeuu se podría llegar a un acuerdo
junto a los países centroamericanos
después de esta gira
si el problema es que eeuu ha
cuestionado los programas de
transferencia de efectivo como son el
programa sembrando vidas y el programa
jóvenes construyendo el futuro que son
los programas que implementa méxico a
través de sus agencias en estos países
de américa este de américa santa no se
ha cuestionado porque dice que no son
transparentes que no ofrecen resultados
y que bueno hay poca retroalimentación
política entonces mientras no hay un
acuerdo en cómo implementar estos
programas tampoco va a haber
financiamiento por parte del gobierno
estadounidense el gobierno estadunidense
lo que está haciendo es financiar
programas propios a través de ese
entonces tenemos dos estrategias la
estadounidense y la mexicana para tener
un mismo problema que son las causas
profundas de la migración proveniente
del triángulo norte de centroamérica
y este sábado se espera también la
llegada de obrador a cuba- oficialmente
para abordar temas de amistad entre
ambos países que temas importantes
pueden tratar y llegar a una posición
conjunta respecto a la cumbre de las
américas a la que recordemos eeuu no
quiere invitar a cuba
si la relación entre méxico y cuba ha
sido fundamental recordemos por ejemplo
que en la celebración de 2021 de la
independencia de méxico dos días después
de que méxico había recibido las cartas
credenciales del embajador
estadounidense ken salazar méxico invita
al presidente cubano a díaz canel como
el invitado de honor durante el haro y
la el desfile de independencia de mexico
entonces desde ahí se mostró como iba a
haber una presión y se hizo patente con
un discurso del presidente mexicano de
que se redujeran las tensiones o las
sanciones económicas entre estados
unidos y la isla entonces bueno sabemos
que va a ser una situación de bastante
cooperación y que inevitablemente es va
a tocar una presión en este tema de
presionar a eeuu para que cuba pueda
asistir a la cumbre de las américas que
se va a celebrar el próximo junio